Nuestro contacto allí era George y dirige el club de fotografía de la comunidad.
Él se las arregló para que nos encontráramos
con otras parejas en su estudio fotográfico improvisado.
SB: Después de 45 años de matrimonio, el esposo de Anastasia murió hace 2 años,
así que le preguntamos si tenía alguna foto antigua de la boda.
Ella conoció a su esposo
con 15 años, cuando era camarera en una pequeña barbacoa en Michigan.
Él tenía 30.
Y le mintió acerca de su edad.
Él fue la primera persona con quién ella salió.
Dean ha sido nombrado el fotógrafo del año en Las Vegas dos años seguidos,
y esto llamó la atención de Alec,
como también el hecho de que conoció a su esposa, Judy,
a la misma edad con la que Alec conoció a Rachel.
Dean admitió que le gusta mirar a las mujeres hermosas,
pero nunca cuestionó su decisión de casarse con Judy.
AS: George conoció a Josefina en un baile de la parroquia.
Él tenía 18 años, ella tenía 15.
Al igual que muchas de las parejas que conocimos,
no filosofaban mucho
acerca de sus primeras decisiones.
George me dijo algo que me quedó grabado.
Me dijo: "Cuando te llega ese sentimiento, te dejas llevar".
Bob y Trudy se conocieron en una cita a ciegas
cuando ella todavía estaba en la escuela secundaria.
Nos dijeron que no se sintieron atraídos el uno por el otro
cuando se conocieron.
No obstante, se casaron poco después.
SB: La historia que más me impactó
fue la de George, el presidente del club de fotografía, y de su esposa, María.
Este matrimonio fue el segundo para los dos.
Se conocieron en un club country en Louisville, Kentucky, llamado Sahara.
Él estaba allí solo, bebiendo, y ella estaba con amigos.
Cuando empezaron de novios, él le debía al IRS USD 9000 en impuestos,
y ella se ofreció a ayudarle a saldar la deuda,
así que durante el año siguiente, el le entregaba parte de dinero a María,
y ella le pagó la deuda.
George era en realidad alcohólico cuando se casaron, y María lo sabía.
Reconoció que en algún momento de su matrimonio,
llegó a consumir 54 cervezas en un día.
En otra ocasión, al emborracharse, amenazó con matar a María
y a sus dos hijos,
pero ella se libró llamando al equipo SWAT.
Sorprendentemente, María le dejo volver,
y, finalmente, las cosas mejoraron.
George se apuntó a Alcohólicos Anónimos
y lleva sin beber 36 años.
(Música)
Al final del día, después de salir de Sun City,
le dije a Alec que en realidad no me parecía
que las historias de cómo estas parejas se conocieron fueran muy interesantes.
Lo que era más interesante
era cómo se las arreglaron para permanecer juntos.
AS: Todos tenían esta hermosa característica de resistencia,
pero eso era cierto para los solteros también.
El mundo es duro, y los solteros están allí,
tratando de conectarse con otras personas,
mientras que en las parejas se aferran el uno al otro,
después de todos estos años.
Mis imágenes favoritas de este viaje son las de Joe y Roseanne.
En el momento en el que conocimos a Joe y Roseanne
ya teníamos el hábito de pedirles a las parejas
una vieja fotografía de la boda.
En su caso, sacaron de sus carteras, al mismo tiempo
la misma fotografía.
¿Qué es más hermoso, me dije a mí mismo,
esta foto de una joven pareja que acaba de enamorarse
o la idea de que estas dos personas
han guardado esta foto durante décadas?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)